what if I told you whichever candidate
was favored they want to become the U.S
president actually ends up losing and
the underdog nobody is paying attention
to is typically the one that wins so we
went back and looked at numbers our
research team here's what we noticed Jeb
Bush most money raised lost Hillary
Clinton most money raised twice she lost
once to Obama once to Trump now just a
couple months ago they were talking
about the fact that Ron DeSantis the
great Governor nobody did a better job
than him during covert no one that I'm
in Florida because of him 130 million
dollars with a Super PAC another 20
million dollar race everyone said it's
over with this guy's gonna win it
they're about to fire a third of their
staff so this is what we did we went and
found list of people that were the
biggest underdogs that ended up winning
we looked at who raised how much money
what qualities people look at what gaps
they had and then a couple funny clips
will show you and who is the current
Underdog that could eventually be your
presence
thank you
okay so if you get value from this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into it so the
biggest triumphs underdogs coming out of
nowhere the first one we're going to
look at is Abraham Lincoln against
William Seward in 1860 the Republicans
expected to win the presidency with
their strong candidate William H Seward
a polished influential former governor
and senator from New York his only
serious rival for the party's nomination
was Abraham Lincoln a politician from
the backwood states of Illinois who was
little known in the powerful eastern
states Lincoln proved a better
politician as a native son he secured
all the votes from the Illinois
delegates his campaign workers made sure
to seat Lincoln's supporters close to
critical delegations they printed
counterfeit admission tickets to the
convention to pack the hall with Lincoln
backers and leave little room for Seward
supporters and through these tactics and
backroom bargaining Lincoln gained the
nomination in November he won the
presidency because the anti-republican
votes were divided between three
pro-slavery candidates and now some say
Ram Lincoln is one of the greatest
presidents we've ever had next Truman
against Dewey 5
Underdog Truman had taken office after
Roosevelt's death in 1945 and face
challenges during his term even the
newspaper announced Dewey defeats Truman
based on early results and expectation
nobody thought Truman was going to win
but Truman traveled nearly 22 000 Miles
by election day at one point given 13
speeches in one day and they were set to
be very passionate speeches advocated
for civil rights and USSR containment
considered one of the biggest political
comebacks of all time and maybe one of
the greatest pictures ever taken in
politics in newspapers is when Truman is
holding the paper that says Dewey
defeats Truman the ultimate Underdog
Story at the time he makes in the top
five stories the next one is Nixon
against John F Kennedy this is very
interesting because nobody knew who John
F Kennedy was they kind of looked at him
as look your father Joseph's been doing
everything for you yeah your Congress
yeah your Senate but Nixon two-term vice
president like this is the guy that's
gonna be the next president but what
ends up happening the national sentiment
turned in Kennedy's favor when the first
televised debates were held Kennedy was
much better looking and charismatic then
Nixon what a lot of people don't know
the night before Nixon didn't shave he
didn't think it was a big deal because
when it was on radio Nixon had a great
voice like this guy's got it on TV JFK
went to sleep he was very well rested he
went to tanning bed he looked good Nixon
had a flu obviously all of this worked
against Nixon and knowing the fact that
JFK's dad Joseph was a master at
marketing he's kind of behind closer
saying here's what we're going to do
this is what's going to happen my son's
a better looking guy you're going to win
in this area and obviously worked in
their favor this was enough to give JFK
razor thin victory over the favorite
Richard Nixon this next one's a little
bit crazy because it's Reagan against
Carter most of the time when we hear the
story we hear about the shellacking you
know Reagan Gabe Carter because it's
like oh 49 out of 50 States but what
most people don't realize Carter was the
president he was incumbent and he's
going up against the governor but up
until the last week President Carter had
a definite lead even with America's
concern about the economy and the Iran
hostage crisis he still had the lead
Reagan turned it around with his
polished performance in the campaign's
One televised debate it had one of the
highest TV ratings of any show in the
previous decade that debate has
remembered for radiant squips there you
go again and are you better off now than
you were four years ago Ronald Reagan
ended up winning the 1980 election in a
definitive and unprecedented Landslide
you ready
489-49
489-49 never has there been something
this embarrassing what's wild about this
is guys he won 44 out of 50 states think
about that it's one of the most
embarrassing losses ever because Carter
had the lead and last minute Reagan
makes a comeback and obviously the rest
is history so before we go to Obama
Hillary and McCain let me give you a
quick respect to Bill Clinton against
President Bush senior two-term vice
president director of CIA one-term
president father Senator Prescott I mean
this is a legacy type of a family you're
going up against who are you Bill
Clinton from Arkansas from Hope from
being the the cutest two-year-old boy I
was in Hope Arkansas went to his house
where he was born and I saw he won all
these awards for being a cute boy he was
a cute boy himself went and asked
everybody about Bill Clinton but being a
president my wife and Bill Clinton went
to the same middle school okay not the
same age but to the same middle school
and he was the first President I ever
shook hands when I was working at
Haagen-Dazs in Glendale Galleria he
shook this kid's hand his second term he
got my vote first president and I ever
voted for and I made fifty dollars off
his book with an uncle of mine well Bill
Clinton comes out of nowhere and he
beats senior and Senior becomes a
one-term president and now senior will
say was all Ross Pro's fault but
regardless of what happens this
charismatic Center left distancing
himself from traditional liberals ends
up becoming a president and a two-ton
President Bill Clinton but let's go to
the last one here we got Obama McCann
here's a part of what Obama Obama gives
a speech in 2008 that's great but
Hillary Clinton I mean this is like
Senator Secretary of State husband's a
two-term President Clinton's got a very
strong Ward it's one of the most
powerful political families in America
the most powerful political couple in
America both way more than Michelle and
Barack Obama today and she decides to
run no one's supposed to beat her
definitely not this one-term senator who
are you one-term Senator motivational
speaker you're not going to beat me not
only does he beat her then he goes up
against McCain who has a resume this
thick of a resume a prisoner of war this
guy's got one of the best resumes ever
and what ends up happening when you look
at this chart here in 2008 at first
Obama wins Iowa caucuses so he's got a
lead then all of a sudden super Tuesday
takes place and McCain's got the lead
okay so he wins the Florida primary and
like no McCain's going to win it then
next thing you know boom right after
super Tuesday Obama takes off he wins
the nomination everything's going their
way then suddenly right before election
time a couple weeks before it McCain
takes a lead right after AIG seized
Lehman Brothers bankruptcy all that
stuff's going on they said we got to
kind of lean on this McCain guy then all
of a sudden it's as if Obama went on a
run and it was game over he ended up
winning 365 173 wasn't even close but he
was an underdog and he beat two
favorites heavyweight Hillary Clinton
and heavyweight McCain at the same time
now before I give you the last one
you're on the greatest like Underdog guy
winning president all this stuff I think
you kind of know where I'm going I want
to give you some data before I go
through that so here's how much money's
been raised since 1960 till today for
every single election if you look at
Nixon against Kennedy Nixon raised 10.1
million Kennedy raised 9.8 million
Kennedy ends up winning next one
Goldwater raised 16 million Johnson
raises 8.8 but guess who wins Johnson
wins next one Dixon raises 25.4 million
Humphrey raises 11.6 more than doubling
Nixon obviously wins Nixon raises 61.4
million doubling McGovern Nixon wins
next 435 Carter 33 Carter wins Reagan
57.7 million car to 49 million Reagan
wins next one Reagan raises 67 and a
half a million more than Mondale Reagan
wins Bush senior 80-77 Dukakis Bush
senior wins again boy senior versus
Clinton 97 million to 107.9 million
Clinton wins Dole 66.8 goes against
Clinton 115 million this is Bill Clinton
Bill Clinton wins then he got Bush Jr
going against Gore 60 million dollars
more race Bush wins Bush again beats
Kerry he raised 355 carry race 332 Bush
wins McCain against Obama Obama nearly
4X became 760 to 239 million Obama wins
and the next one Obama Against Romney
737 to Romney's 483 Obama wins then if
you look at Hillary Clinton against
Trump Hillary Clinton 580 Trump 340
Trump wins Biden against Trump Biden
raised 1.68 billion Trump raised 1
billion 60 million and Biden wins so if
you look at this and see how many times
a person who raised less money won you
would notice it's Kennedy it's Johnson
it's Carter and Trump almost every
single time whoever raised more money
wins the whole thing these are some of
the underdogs so so here's what you'll
notice if we look at this and we think
about a pattern there's only been four
times where somebody who raised less
money won one is Kennedy 60. one is
Johnson 64. the other is Carter 76 and
the other is Trump 2016. the last time
somebody who raised less money he raised
half the money Hillary did the last time
that happened was 1976 it hasn't
happened for 40 years right so now if we
look at this and we go to the Trump
Hillary campaign what will you notice
this is what you'll notice I want you to
look at this election odds okay well
who's going to win if you look at the
dates Trump versus Clinton Clinton had a
negative 110 odds that means you have to
bet 110 200 and with Trump as of August
5th 2015 you had to bet if you bet a
hundred dollars you would have won
twenty five hundred dollars and it goes
goes goes goes goes goes all the way up
to October 25th on October 25th a week
and a half before voting in order for
you to win a hundred dollars with
Hillary Clinton you had to bet 550 to
win a hundred dollars and with Trump if
you bet a hundred dollars you win 350.
you know what that tells you everybody
sat in and said guys come on let's not
get it twisted Hillary Clinton is going
to be our next president Trump is out
everybody knew this however there's a
couple things I remember I would be on
Facebook and I would see Trump six seven
eight nine ten Facebook lives in
different places he's given a speech and
you would only see Hillary given one
speech a week two speech a week I'm
sitting there saying 50 70 000 people
are coming to see this guy how is this
possible this guy's gonna lose us kind
of crazy but maybe maybe she raised
twice as much money than him maybe
that's what it is the ads are going to
work and then what results did we get
all of us at two o'clock in the morning
three o'clock in the morning president
Donald Trump and you see Donald Trump
walking on stage with him and his wife
you're like wait they don't even think
they won look at their they were super
even he said it I looked at Ivanka I'm
like do we really win this thing we did
pretty wild man I didn't think we were
going to be presidents and he gets a
call from Hillary Clinton now let me go
a little bit more because there are
certain qualities that Gallup did to say
who was likelihood to become the
president based on what qualities there
are four people they're looking at here
these were like the four candidates they
thought was most likely to become
president Hillary Clinton Ted Cruz
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump out of
all of these things that they have which
is I want to say it's 12 different
qualities Trump only was leading in two
out of the 12. let me give you exactly
these qualities intense Bernie Sanders
won that with 44 competitive Bernie
Sanders first place inspiring Hillary
Clinton 71 no one even was in 60s
courageous Hillary Clinton 61. no one
was even in the 50s prepared Trump
beating Hillary by one consistent
Hillary enthusiastic Hillary got 50.
Trump only got 27. cares about
individuals Trump got 68 beating Hillary
by 161 percent and the rest it's a sweep
emphasize success Hillary Clinton 52
Trump only 25. Trump is like his brain
is success but they give it to Hillary
Gallup analytical Hillary 53 focused
Hillary 44 Visionary Hillary 65 but at
the end of the day we know who won Trump
won and by the way Hillary Clinton lost
to a one-term senator and lost to Trump
who's never ran for office before and
she's got the biggest imagine being that
like your entire dream for 50 years has
been to become the president and you
miss out but there's a couple things you
need to look at here together so in 2010
they passed the Citizens United versus
FEC it's important to know this the
Supreme Court ruled five to four that
the freedom of speech Clause of the
First Amendment prohibits the government
from a restricted independent
expenditures for political campaigns by
corporations including non-profit
corporations labor unions and other
associations this ruling allow
corporations and other outside groups to
spend keyword unlimited money on
elections look at the kind of money we
raise when you look at this chart from
statista in 2003 2004 election we raised
891 million dollars total presidential
election 2008 it doubles that's the
Obama year to 1.769 billion next one 1.4
billion next one 1.529 billion that's
Trump Hillary but look at 2020 when it's
Biden Trump 4 billion 50 eight million
dollars almost more money than the three
previous elections that is insane to
think that people at the top can just
have an open checkbook to spend money
and say I'm literally going to buy your
presidency is what I'm gonna do because
I'm going to run non-stop negative ads
until you win so when you look at this
when you look at some candidates RFK why
is he getting momentum nobody thought he
was gonna everybody thought he's just a
conspiracy theory guy writing a book
against voucher because he's pissed off
on fauci isn't he an environmental
lawyer on he's got a bad voice this guy
shouldn't be doing a better job than
somebody's who's this Yvette guy by the
way I don't even know 37 years old he's
a billionaire he comes in he makes a lot
of sense why is he getting all these
eyeballs he's everywhere everywhere I
look at here he's here Dennis here
Dennis here then he's here he's about to
do a town hall with us next week he's
going to be with us here why is he
everywhere he's the underdog Trump
against the Santa some would say Trump
in a way was an underdog based on who
raised more money you look at these
different things you start realizing
money matters but it's not just money
they said five qualities to be a
president number one personal success
like you have to be a winner number two
demonstrated commitment into the
community people have to trust that you
care about them number three Integrity
are you honest number four intelligence
and number five consistent political
philosophies this definitely didn't work
for John Kerry when he was flip-flopping
because they said you don't really have
consistent philosophies to one crowd you
say one thing to another crowd you say
another thing we don't believe you
you're not consistent we don't want you
even though you're a Yale guy so they
look at that stuff now if you look at
this next one what Democrats care about
versus Republicans empathy Democrats
care about that 69 to Republicans 48
strength 76 to 64 Republicans honesty
Democrats value that 81-71 audacity
Republicans valued at 38-28 taking
responsibility it's about the same but
Democrats 85 Republicans 80. competence
777 this is when Biden was going up
against Trump and when they measured the
two against each other strength they
give it to Trump 89-64 competence they
give it to Trump takes responsibility
they give it to Biden honesty they give
it to Biden audacity they definitely
gave that to Trump and empathy they give
it to Biden by 20 points and we know who
won so picking who's going to win day
one without us even having seen a single
debate yet it's very early to do so
anybody can make a combat including the
Santas but you have to pay attention to
a lot of different factors it's not just
one thing or another and by the way when
you look at some of the most
embarrassing gaps we can find a lot of
them here's one of them Marco Rubio
against Chris Christie when Chris
Christie said watch he keeps saying this
one liner over and over again and the
line was this notion that Barack Obama
doesn't know what he's doing matter of
fact I'll just let you see when Chris
Christie calls him out here he is let's
dispel with this fiction that Barack
Obama
this campaign is so important now
obviously right after that people said
Marco Rubio was done with there's no way
he can compete and it was pretty much
done for him the next one a lot of
people think Joe Biden is the goat for
falling before there was a Joe Biden
there was a Bob Dole and Bob Dole's
fault is by far a greater fall now
obviously we don't want anybody to get
hurt when you fall like this this video
is going to be shown everywhere matter
of fact Bob Dole if he felt like this
today that clip would be getting
billions of views here's the clip of Bob
Dole Fallen
[Music]
this next one got to give it to Obama
and his marketing campaign Romney gets
up and gives us incredible song and then
Romney's campaign takes that song it
opens it up with Obama saying I endorse
this message and Romney is singing this
song and then they said everything
Romney is touching he has money in
Bermuda he has money in Caymans here's
what he's doing to his employees is this
a person you want to solve your problems
he's not at boom Obama uses that helps
him Romney's out they go with Obama I'm
Barack Obama and I approve this message
oh beautiful four spacious guys
forever waves of gray or purple
mountains
fruit and plane
America America
and last but not least this is this
guy's got to be the goat I mean this is
I mean I don't think anyone's going to
come at this guy's level Howard Dean
crushed it at one point for a split
second he thought he was the second
coming of Tony Robbins I'll just let you
judge it for yourself
you know something
if you had told us one year ago that we
were going to come in third in Iowa we
would have given anything for that and
you know something
you know something not only are we going
to New Hampshire Tom Hawkins we're going
to South Carolina and Oklahoma and
Arizona and North Dakota and New Mexico
we're going to California and Texas and
New York and we go to South Dakota and
Oregon and Washington and Michigan and
then we're going to Washington DC to
take back the White House
[Applause]
I mean you didn't have to do that bro
what are you doing screaming I mean who
told you that's a good idea it's over
for him right after that and last but
not least Dukakis is going up against
Bush and he's trying to sell the fact
that he's tough in the military and then
his team somebody on this team thought
this was a good idea when they did this
it was a laughing stock it was over
after this day check this out
Michael Dukakis as opposed virtually
every defense system we developed the
opposed new aircraft carriers he opposed
anti-satellite weapons he opposed four
missile systems including urging two
missile deployment
and a ground emergency warning system
against nuclear attack
he even criticized our rescue mission to
Grenada and our strike on Libya and now
he wants to be our commander-in-chief
America can't afford that risk
terrible idea but somebody thought it
was a good idea look we can say
one-liners you know there you go again
because you'd be in jail you know how
many one-liners we can come up with on
all this stuff to give it to them
there's so many factors that goes into
this but this is why when I had Ari
Fleischer here on the podcast and I said
there's so many different Industries for
you to get into to make money why
politics he says because I love
competition and there is nothing better
he says in every competition there's a
score you can say you shoot a
three-pointer you get three points you
catch a touchdown six points you get the
extra point one point he says the only
sport that there is no way to score a
point but who can sell ideas better and
who's a marketer is politics he says you
gotta love this competition this is why
so many people tune in now a big part
outside of competition it's also
policies that's going to dictate which
direction America goes so a lot is on
the line but it's way too early for us
to decide who's going to be the
president in 2024. so if you got value
out of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel I got another
video I want you to watch is the
anti-establishment presidents and and
why free thinkers if you're a free
thinker if you're a true value tainer
you're typically somebody that's
anti-establishment if you've never seen
this video before I highly recommend you
watching this click here to watch that
video take care everybody bye bye
foreign